hey guys i'm ryan wright and i am also
jerry welcome to reasons to see super
straight to the point review of the
hunger games catching fire
so let's hang out for a brief moment
yeah okay this film it's the reason
movies are made it's awesome cinematic
experience how is it jennifer lawrence
she [ __ ] rocks all the cast is great
i mean in this movie i gotta give it
props because it it's dark man they
didn't skimp this for anybody's audience
they just made the movie they wanna made
it seems like yeah definitely the whole
cast is fantastic josh hutcherson he
rocks it again i love him more in this
one than the other one i like jennifer
lawrence more on this one than the other
one lenny kravitz lenny kravitz is back
woody harrelson is back and he does a
great job all your favorite people are
back plus some new people who are pretty
rad too oh yeah man you get you get a
whole shitload of new characters man
we're [ __ ] awesome even philip
seymour hoffman is the [ __ ] even wes
bentley is mentioned a couple times yes
yeah see you have to see the first one
to understand it yeah but this one i
mean it's like i dug the first one but i
dug this one even more it's a much
bigger adventure the scope is much
bigger too and it's not the same thing
but more it's it's actually like oh it's
a whole there's a whole thing we didn't
even realize was going on in the first
movie it's darker there's more drama
visual effects [ __ ] dynamite rad
there's so much design and it's all
ridiculous you know and i thought the
directing and cinematography greatly
improved i love the first directing
don't get me wrong but i i thought it
was even better this time around man
it's more fluid and everything and watch
it on imax it makes more sense for this
one to be shot the way it is yeah it's a
logical progression so yeah this film is
the [ __ ] it's pretty rad alright guys
thanks for checking out our super
straight to the point review of the
hunger games catching fire don't you go
ahead and scroll that comment box below
and tell us do you think josh hutcherson
is attractive and if you want to see a
more in-depth review a more in-depth
discussion of hunger games catching fire
why don't you go and check out our show
reasons to see where we give you an
in-depth breakdown of reasons to see
and reasons not to see
the hunger games yeah catching fire and
last but not least
please do this because we want you to
hang out with us every week it'd be nice
see this button
subscribe to it
subscribe to the button subscribe you
want to
or else you'll get set on fire
and no one will be there to catch you no
no and you'll be very hungry while this
is going up yeah
yeah and people will be betting so it'll
be kind of a game yeah
like how fast you die because you didn't
subscribe in time [ __ ]
[ __ ]
mr white [ __ ]
you